[Music]
Razors new blade is a beautiful and
powerful gaming laptop and while it's
similar to last year's model in many
ways it's also $400 more expensive for a
product that's already pricier than the
competition that price increase raises
some alarms as you'd expect the hardware
on the inside is stronger and more
capable at gaming under higher settings
but it's the new display that stands out
as the most notable upgrade it's
extremely sharp and doubles as a touch
panel but does that justify the extra
cost let's take a look if you put razors
new blade next to last year's model you
might have a hard time telling the two
apart the only real difference being
that the new blade is slightly thicker
at 0.7 inches which is still
impressively thin considering what's on
the inside at 4.7 pounds it's not
unusually light but it's on the better
end of the gaming laptop scale razors
bright green accents the logo on the lid
do stand out but the blades largely
understated and pretty sleek which isn't
something you can say about most gaming
laptops the black anodized aluminum
chassis looks great but it comes with
one downside it transfers heat so well
that it's impossible to keep the blade
on your lap ball gaming or watching HD
videos is it a trade-off yes but it's
not a deal-breaker apart from the GPU
this year's blade is nearly identical on
the inside to last year's model it has
the same processor a quad core intel
core i7 4702 HQ at 2.2 gigahertz in the
same RAM configuration with 8 gigabytes
of 1600 megahertz ddr3 memory for the
new GPU Razer has gone for the fresh
Nvidia 870 M with three gigabytes of
gddr5 vram onboard the 870 M outperforms
last year's 765 M in every case but this
added performance comes at a cost
the 875 M draws 100 watts of power where
last year's 765 only needed 75 watts and
given that razors using the same battery
as last year the new blade won't last
long on the go when you push the GPU to
its limits the blade will typically last
just over an hour in our experience
although this can be extended a bit with
conservative graphics settings otherwise
expect three to four hours of battery
life during non gaming sessions
the display on last year's blade had a
maximum resolution of 1600 by 900 pixels
given the physical dimensions it was
adequate but not impressive this time
around the opposite is true
razor went all out and opted for a 3200
by 1800 qhd+ display with 10-point
multi-touch capabilities it's a
magnificent screen that produces vibrant
colors in any light and its contents for
me invisible from every angle shy of 90
degrees the blade screen is impressive
on many levels but art specs necessary
for a gaming laptop a 1080p or 1440p
display would have been perfectly
acceptable and it's not really clear why
a gaming laptop needs a touch panel yes
it's a display that's easy to appreciate
but it's over-the-top features come at a
significant cost there's also the fact
that you likely won't play any of your
games at the blades native resolution
given that it would be far too taxing on
any gaming PC if you're aiming for
decent graphics settings let alone the
blade as such that means you'll have to
deal with some minor inconveniences for
one some applications including Origen
don't scale correctly but more
importantly when you try to play a game
at 1080p you're treated to a small
in-game display in the middle of a large
black screen the solution here is pretty
simple set the desktop resolution to
match the game you're going to play you
could always leave the desktop
resolution at 1920 by 1080 to avoid this
hassle but then everything in Windows is
slightly larger than it should be
there's nothing worse than a laptop with
a poorly designed keyboard and a finicky
touch but these are things you'd never
say about the blade the keyboards
chiclet style keys feel great and
they're perfectly spaced it's easy to
draw comparisons to the keys on a
MacBook Pro which is a good sign the
touchpad is also worthy of praise with a
smooth and responsive surface that works
well with Windows 8 multi-touch gestures
presenting no issues whatsoever during
our tests the buttons below the touchpad
aren't as pleasing as the rest of the
inputs being thin and slightly mushy but
they still get the job done looking at
the inputs on the side of the blade
nothing's changed since last year on the
left side you've got the power supply
connection two USB 3.0 ports and a 3.5
millimeter microphone headphone combo
port and on the other an HDMI port and
one more USB 3.0 connection it's a shame
that there's not an Ethernet port but
there's built-in 802 1011 AVGN EC Wi-Fi
and support for Bluetooth 4.0 if you
want more reliable and faster internet
access you'll have to shell out for an
Ethernet USB adapter for a thin gaming
laptop the blade handles demanding games
including watchdogs Admiral
you're best off aiming for high or very
high graphic settings rather than ultra
but that's if you're chasing 60 frames
per second if you're okay with 30 frames
per second you can eke out a little more
performance from the blades GPU and CPU
in most cases you can find other laptops
that offer better performance for less
money but you ultimately sacrifice
Portability and build well the
importance of which should not be
underestimated that aside you won't be
disappointed by the blades performance
you won't be able to play every game
with ultra settings but you can get
close in most cases the blade that razor
supplied for our review is the 256
gigabyte model which costs around $2,400
before taxes the base model with 128
gigabyte solid state drive gets off the
ground at 2,200 dollars and the high-end
model with 512 gigabytes cost about
$2,700 the blade is definitely a premium
high-end laptop and it's easy to balk at
the price tag but when the blades in
your hands it's really hard not to fall
in love with its sleek portable and
powerful enough to keep any PC gamer on
the go in a good mood any model of the
blade is a really nice laptop and if
budgets are concerned don't discount
last year's model which is currently on
sale for $1,700 but if you've got money
to spend there's no other gaming laptop
on the market that I would recommend
more than razors new blade
[Music]
you